MAKE REAL THOSE PROMISES.
>> Gregg: WE FOUGHT THE
REVOLUTION TO IMPEACH.
IDIOTIC, OF COURSE.
MIND-BOGGLING.
DEMOCRATS ARE PLANNING TO HOLD A
NEW IMPEACHMENT HEARING THIS
COMING WEDNESDAY WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE AT THE
NATO SUMMIT IN LONDON.
GREAT TIMING, JERRY NADLER.
THIS IS YET ANOTHER INSTANCE OF
TONE-DEAF DEMOCRATS TRYING TO
UNDERMINE THE PRESIDENT WHILE HE
IS ABROAD.
IN JULY OF 2017, YOU MAY RECALL
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS AT A BUS
STEEL DAY WHEN DEMOCRATS
INTRODUCED ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT AGAINST HIM.
FEBRUARY 2019, THE PRESIDENT
ATTENDED A SUMMIT WITH
PRESIDENT KIM JONG UN, AND IN
JULY OF 2019, THE PRESIDENT
ATTENDED A DJ CELEBRATION IN
FRANCE AND THAT IS WHEN
CONGRESSMAN JERRY NADLER CHOSE
TO PURSUE MORE RUSSIA WHICH FOUD
HEARINGS.
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION IS
SENIOR LEGAL ADVISOR TO THE
TRUMP 2020 CAMPAIGN, JENNA
ELLIS.
HOUSE FREEDOM CAUCUS CHAIRMAN,
CONGRESSMAN ANDY BIGGS.
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR ROY
MURDOCK.
CONGRESSMAN BIGS, LET ME START
WITH YOU.
IS IT YOUR SENSE THAT DEMOCRATS
ARE CATCHING AN EAR FULL BACK
HOME AMONG THEIR CONSTITUENTS
AND THAT THEY MAY SUDDENLY GET A
CASE OF THE 4-REAL OR LESS AND
RECONSIDER THEIR DRIVE TO
IMPEACH?
>> IN SOME DISTRICTS THEY ARE.
IF YOU ARE IN A SWING DISTRICT
LIKE THE STATE YOU JUST SHOWED A
CLIP OF, THEY ARE FEELING SOME
HEAT, SOME DISCOMFORT ABOUT
PURSUING IMPEACHMENT.
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF WHAT CAME
OUT IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS OF THE
OPEN HEARINGS.
SO FIRST OF ALL, IT IS OBTUSE.
NOBODY CAN REALLY EXPLAIN WHAT
THE CHARGES ARE.
SO THE PEOPLE THERE WHO HAVE
SAID, WE WANT IMPEACHMENT, WHO
ARE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS IN A
SWING DISTRICT ARE NOW FEELING
THE HEAT ABOUT, YOU CAN'T EVEN
TELL US WHAT THE ISSUE IS.
SO YEAH, THEY ARE FEELING IT IN
SOME RESPECTS.
THAT IS WHY I THINK THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR AN OFF-RAMP IN SOME
RESPECTS, IF THEY CAN GET ON AND
OFF RAMP.
>> Gregg: YEAH, WELL, THERE
ARE PLENTY OF OFF-RAMP'S ON THAT
FREEWAY.
DEROY MURDOCK, YOU PENNED A
COLUMN THAT WILL BE COMING OUT
SHORTLY.
YOU SHARED IT WITH ME IN
ADVANCE.
YOU WRITE THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
ON THE VERGE OF GETTING WHAT
THEY WANTED AND THEY WILL BE
SORRY.
HOW SO?
>> I THINK THEY MAY HAVE LEARNED
TO HATE THEIR LITTLE IMPEACHMENT
TOY, WHICH THEY JUST UNWRAPPED.
AMONG OTHER THINGS, THEIR TIMING
IS HORRIBLE.
WE ARE NOT JUST FINISHING UP
THANKSGIVING, WE'VE GOT THE
HEARINGS OF IMPEACHMENT, THE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT, THE
DEBATE ON IMPEACHMENT, ALL THAT
STUFF WILL BE GOING ON WHILE
AMERICANS ARE TRIMMING CHRISTMAS
TREES, GOING SHOPPING, ENJOYING
EGG NOW, GOING TO CHRISTMAS
PARTIES, GETTING READY TO LIGHT
THE HANUKKAH CANDLES, DOING ALL
THESE WARM, LOVING THINGS IN THE
DEMOCRATS WILL BE ON TV DIVIDING
THE COUNTRY, AND IF THEY DO
DECIDE TO HOLD THESE HEARINGS,
THE TRIAL WILL BE TAKING PLACE
AT THE SAME TIME OF THE NEVADA
CAUCUSES, AND MAY BE IN THE
SOUTH CAROLINA CAUCUS TAKING
PLACE WHERE SENATOR SANDERS, AND
WARREN AND BOOKER,
KAMALA HARRIS, AMY KLOBUCHAR
WILL BASICALLY BE TIED UP ON THE
SENATE FLOOR UNABLE TO DO
ANYTHING WHILE THEY WOULD MUCH
RATHER BE OUT THERE CAMPAIGNING.
IT IS TURNED THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARIES TOTALLY UPSIDE DOWN.
>> Gregg: IN BATTLEGROUND
STATES LIKE WISCONSIN, I NOTE
ACCORDING TO THE POLLING DATA,
40% SUPPORT EIGHT.
53% ARE AGAINST IMPEACHMENT.
BUT WHAT IS IMPORTANT IS HOW
INDEPENDENTS ARE BREAKING
AGAINST IMPEACHMENT BY AN
11-POINT MARGIN.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK INDEPENDENTS ARE
EXCELLENT HERE BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
ACCUSE INDEPENDENTS OF POLITICAL
TRIBALISM.
THE FACT THAT THESE DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING HOME TO THEIR
DISTRICTS AND THEY ARE BEING
FACED WITH INDEPENDENTS WHO ARE
SAYING, WE ARE NOT FOR THE SPEED
WE DIDN'T PUT YOU IN OFFICE TO
DO THIS.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN, AND THE
REASONABLE AMERICAN ARE SEEING
THAT THIS IS JUST A COMPLETE
SHAM.
THIS IS NOT WHAT THE FOUNDING
FATHERS INTENDED BY THE
SEPARATION OF POWERS WHATSOEVER.
AND FOR MSNBC TO RUN THAT KIND
OF ADDED IS COMPLETELY
ANTITHETICAL NOT ONLY TO WHAT
OUR FOUNDING FATHERS FOUGHT FOR,
BLED FOR, AND DIED FOR, BUT IT
IS COMPLETELY MISUNDERSTANDING
AND COMPLETELY NAVIGATING WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ALL ABOUT AND
HOW HE HAS MADE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN AND HOW HE IS A FIGHTER.
HE IS AN AMERICAN WHO HAS
ADVANCED SO MUCH FOR YOU AND ME,
AND FOR THE VOTERS TO PUT HIM IN
OFFICE, HE HAS ACCOMPLISHED SO
MUCH IN SPITE OF ALL OF THIS
OPPOSITION BECAUSE HE IS MOVING
FORWARD AND MAKING AMERICA
GREAT, AND I THINK THAT THE
INDEPENDENTS ARE SEEING THAT AND
THEY ARE JUST SO SICK AND TIRED
OF THIS WITCH HUNT AND THIS
SHAM.
AND THAT SHOULD TELL THE
DEMOCRATS, BACK OFF.
>> Gregg: CONGRESSMAN BIGGS,
I'VE SAID BEFORE THAT IF THE
DEMOCRATS ARE FOOLISH ENOUGH TO
IMPEACH THEY HAVE TERRIBLY
MISCALCULATED BECAUSE THE TRIAL
IN THE SENATE WILL NOT BE
ANYTHING LIKE ADAM SCHIFF'S
IMPEACHMENT FOREST.
IT'S GOING TO BE JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
TRUMP WON'T BE ON TRIAL.
JOE AND HUNTER BIDEN WILL BE ON
TRIAL ALONG WITH ADAM SCHIFF AND
THE FAKE WHISTLEBLOWER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
EVERY DAY SIX DAYS A WEEK FROM
NOON UNTIL THEY FINISH IN THE
EVENING.
THAT IS THE REQUIREMENT OF THE
SENATE RULES.
SECOND OF ALL THAT IS GOING TO
BE OPEN, AND THIRDLY, THEY ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BRING IN
WITNESSES JUST LIKE YOU SAID.
TO LOOK FOR HUNTER BIDEN,
JOE BIDEN, ADAM SCHIFF, THE
WHISTLEBLOWER, THE SCHIFF TEAM
OF STAFF WHO WORKED WITH THE
WHISTLEBLOWER.
LOOK FOR A REDUX OF COLONEL VINH
MEN.
YOU'VE GOT
KLAPPER, YOU'VE GOT A WHOLE
SERIES OF WITNESSES THAT CAN
COME IN AND LINDSEY GRAHAM HAS P
COME IN AND LINDSEY GRAHAM HAS O
COME IN AND LINDSEY GRAHAM HAS I
COME IN AND LINDSEY GRAHAM HAS E
COME IN AND LINDSEY GRAHAM HAS D
COME IN AND LINDSEY GRAHAM HAS T
COME IN AND LINDSEY GRAHAM HAS A
HE WILL BRING IN THESE TYPES OF
WITNESSES AND THIS WILL GO FOR
QUITE A LENGTH OF TIME AND
INDEED, THE PRIMARIES ARE GOING
TO TURN TOPSY-TURVY FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY THEY WANT IT
TO GO.
THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS THEY
ARE LOOKING FOR AN OFF RAMP AS
WELL.
>> Gregg: YOU ARE NODDING YOUR
HEAD OVER HERE.
>> I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE THAT IF
THIS MELTDOWN CONTINUES, THIS
MAY NOT EVEN COME TO THE HOUSE.
NANCY PELOSI IS VERY SMART ABOUT
COUNTING VOTES AND SHE SEES 16
OF THESE DEMOCRATS GET COLD
FEET, SHE WILL FIND A WAY TO
SAY, MERRY CHRISTMAS, COME BACK
IN JANUARY.
VOTE ON THE TRADE DEAL AND MOVE
ON JUST TO GET AWAY FROM THIS.
>> Gregg: IF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT COMES
OUT AND REALLY DIRTIES UP
OBAMA'S FBI JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES, THAT MAY
GIVE NANCY PELOSI, SCHIFF, AND
JERRY NADLER PAUSE IN THE IDEA
TO IMPEACH.
INDEED, HE MAY LOOK MORE LIKE A